call the fiscal committee meeting to
order
lousy drive today I don't know about
anyone else that uh was out there on uh
93 or um 89 but it was
not fun so anyhow but this will be lots
of fun so I'm really really glad that I
made it here safely
so
um
the first item on the agenda is
acceptance of minutes
of the September 6th
and September 9th meetings
could I have a motion please thank you
made motion made by uh Senator Bradley
seconded by Senator my mind went blank
uh all those in favor please raise your
hand
oh okay all right
uh motion passes
okay
um
is there anyone that desires to take FIS
Oh I thought I did both at the same time
both at the same time yeah
that's quite all right
let's see
uh is there anyone who desires to take
FIS
seeing none
okay
um
the items that will be taken off the
consent calendar
are
under tab 5.
under Tab 7
fis22326.
FIS
fis359
fis22361
uh the Department of Health and Human
Services
and the department of administrative
Services have requested that FIS
22365 be uh
so could I have a motion to accept the
thank you Senator Bradley moves and
your mic is not on
clarification so on Tab 12 we haven't
talked about whether or not the ones
that deep into the agenda are pulled
they're not on consent all right they're
are you ready okay all those in favor
uh Senator Rosenwald
Senator okay thank you
thank you all for coming uh I can't
believe you're leaving this is so much
fun
what a day
FIS 22 uh
326 Department of Health and Human
Services
authorization to reallocate federal
funds in the amount of
500 and
three three two six
good morning Nathan white oh I'm sorry
we did
I did excuse me I'll go back let's still
dollars
in federal funds
so representative erf I believe that you
there you are so as I understand it this
grant is to administer an ongoing
demonstration program
can you provide an overview of what new
is being demonstrated and how the
development will play out through the
September 2026 time frame
and when the program can be expected to
impact the general fund in the budget
cycle
Santa nello associate commissioner so
for the first 16 months so we just were
awarded the funds the end of August so
for the first 16 months we're really
working on an operational to develop an
operational protocol so that
um
we can determine what we want to do for
services after the first 16 months what
do we want to enhance and so
any people that we transition
from
institutions
would not really impact the general
funds until after this grant award
um because we get an enhanced match for
those folks um through Medicaid
that's later on in the um
proposal
when you say through the grant award the
grant award goes through 2026 correct
correct
yes so then there'll be no impact until
after that until after that correct okay
and what what new might be demonstrated
so one of the things we're really
looking at in the first year is to
really understand
um the home and community-based service
system so that we can enhance that right
um for the for the um seniors that we
serve in the state so we really want to
do some Gap analysis as to wear their
pockets within the state that maybe we
need to enhance home and community-based
services so more people access that we
want to look at some quality measures we
also want to really understand and study
what is needed for a nursing facility
beds within the state so it's really a
lot of research and understanding the
current Service delivery system
Senator Rosenwald thank you madam chair
so we've been we've been running this
program since 2000
seven five we had um an excuse me we had
it originally in 2007 and our program
ended in 2019 and then additional
federal funds were made available
um two states and so New Hampshire
qualified and and really what we want to
look at this round and in the previous
in the previous round we really looked
at okay transitioning people from
institutions into the community and
really our Focus this time around us how
do we divert people and keep them in the
community for as long as possible
thank you so over that 12 years we ran
the program
we transitioned a total of 41 correct
individuals or between three and four
per year correct are we expecting that
this new iteration will be cost neutral
I mean because we've spent a lot of
money on three or four people a year
yeah it definitely because we're really
looking at how do we strengthen our
homing community-based service system so
people don't end up in nursing
facilities and final question sure do do
we actually have the workforce that we
need to be able to keep people in the
CFI program so Workforce is always a
challenge
um and really what we're hoping to do is
through our
assessments and developing the
operational protocol will really
understand that better
thank you you're welcome
so
um
so so this has very much a system of
care feel to it uh and whenever we talk
about system of care and uh the obvious
desirability of building up Community
Based care supports
um I I I'm always left with the question
are these community-based supports going
to be sustainable we've been pumping a
lot of federal money into these programs
and so so I just want us to start to get
our head around the future when it's
it's New Hampshire taxpayers again and
these programs and so it's a very
general sort of comment or concern can
do you want to talk to that
um I I mean I I think what we really
want to try to do is understand how do
we strengthen those systems because
we're spending the money for this
population regardless whether it's in a
nursing facility whether it's in the
Homing in in their own community and we
know the longer people can remain at
home it does bring down the cost of
institutional care and so how do we
shift in that direction
um and really develop what we need to do
to keep people for as long as they want
to be and are able to be safely at home
oh follow it all right so this is what I
think I want to hear you just said I
want to hear that you just said that uh
we're we are going to change the
optimization of the services so that we
reduce our overall cost mix
and hopefully uh at the end of the the
the programs we will be left with
we want to work towards that and work
together in partnership with all of our
partners to make sure that happens that
people can remain at home for as long as
Senator Daniels
thank you I'd like to follow up on some
questions from the senator from Nashua
um if this program started in 20 to 2007
why did we not do any monitoring
you know in in that 12 years to
determine what changes needed to be made
to a system if you're only helping four
people a year
um we did do some monitoring the system
last time was really broad base across
all of the disability communities and
this is really focused on our elderly
and adult service system because we know
with the Aging number of people Aging in
the state that we really want to focus
on this opportunity and and if there's
been more flexibilities actually with
this next round of funding that actually
includes people
um a shorter period of time to be
institutionalized and so Hospital
transfers and all of those pieces will
be super important
to expect the population that you're
going to be dealing with is the same
population as before or is it going to
be expanded and where do you expect that
that the health is going to be given
sure this focus of this round is really
on our elderly and adult service system
so those individuals who are
um eligible for the choices for
Independence waiver but really focused
on our older seniors in the state thank
you
could I have a motion to accept
thank you Senator Bradley second second
this is on 339
representative Edwards on 339 yes okay
yes representative erf yes
representative leishman yes Senator
Daniels yes Senator Bradley yes Senator
gray yes Senator Rosenwald yes Senator
Susie representative umberger yes Madam
chair the vote is 10 yay
motion passes 10-0
we now move to the when I was messed up
on FIS 22
represent Earth did you have questions
I did thank you madam chair
here we go so I'm
and I've really tried hard at this I'm
trying to understand where these federal
funds are coming from and what they were
for the explanation indicates that sabg
funds cannot be used to address alcohol
and related misuse
it also States a Governor's commission
made a presumably previous appropriation
to address this
a response to a question trying to
clarify where the front funds are coming
from referred to two fiscal nodes from
last year
fis21-232 and 21251 both of which as I
read them are sabg and thus presumably
not allowed for alcohol abuse
so I have two questions
the first is a compound question what is
the source of the funds being
transferred in this note
and what were these funds being
transferred originally intended to do
Beyond quote two I.T related
infrastructure projects and the second
question I have relates to the note
itself are the payments actually to
all right I didn't take notes but I I
will try to address all of those
questions with um Nathan's help so for
the record I'm Katya Fox I'm the
director of the division for Behavioral
Health and for this particular item
their substance abuse block grant which
we receive from the federal government
on an annual basis is a certain amount
we received a supplemental block grant
as a result of federal action to
um pandemic and so they are restricted
but the funds that are restricted for
it's a little confusing so we always get
this block grant dollars they have
restrictions
we in addition to the block grant
dollars
um we also receive state opioid response
funds those are the ones that are
restricted from using
um to address the needs of individuals
who have perhaps an alcohol use disorder
versus an opioid use disorder and so the
reference there it's a little confusing
we probably didn't do a good job in that
explanation Sor funds are not at play
we're talking about the block grant
funds in this particular action with the
reference to the fiscal item that was
something that you accepted with the
supplemental and the other funds so
that's the 250 that's referenced here
and I'll explain what we had intended to
use those funds for and then the 300 000
that is from the budget so those were
block grant funds that were in the
budget
okay so 300 000 was in the budget you're
gonna explain to me where in the budget
and the other was where
so it was accepted that's the reference
to the dollars that were accepted last
year by fiscal committee which note
go ahead
or so on on page one of the item that
you have in front of you you'll see uh
account the the last string of numbers
there 1981 the 250 000 that's what was
previously accepted via the fiscal
committee outside of the operating
budget can you tell me what fiscal note
oh what what fiscal item yes so
um that was fiscal item uh approved on
September 17 2021 fist 21 232 okay hang
on so I got that yep and maybe I'm just
misinterpreting what is written here but
I thought it wrote here in this
particular note that sabg funds can't be
used to address alcohol unrelated misuse
to misinterpret that
I I don't have that right in front of me
but that's not the case so s a b g funds
can be used to address all
um substances that someone maybe have an
addiction to okay okay so the reference
was that because of um the one-time
funds we receive from the governor's
commission were used to address the
needs of individuals at the doorways for
non-opioid related issues we are picking
up where the governor's commission funds
left off and using these funds which
have been identified and I'll get to
that part of your question if you'd like
me to yes so the 250 had been set aside
and when we developed these proposals we
have a short amount of time we have
brainstorming sessions within the
department to address what gaps are
there and so the original intent of that
2 250 was to invest in what is known as
prescription digital Therapeutics and
that boils down to it is an adjunct to
treatment services and it's really an
app and it provides at the individual
level of physician the ability to see
how a patient is doing and so that
project never got off the ground so that
probably whatever it would have required
a
uh RFP a request for proposals and gone
through that process so those funds
didn't move forward for that purpose and
we're asking that they be repurposed for
the doorway unmet needs
thank you
seeing none could I have a motion move
the item
representative erf seconded by Senator
Bradley
will the clerk please call the roll
column three two six representative
Edwards yes on three two six yes
representative yes representative
leishman yes Senator Daniels yes Senator
Bradley yes Senator gray yes Senator
Rosenwald yes Senator Susie
representative umberger yes Madam chair
of the vote is 10-0 the vote being 10-0
foreign
to FIS
22 351
I do not need safety up yet what I need
is
um
commissioner Caswell
or whomever
to come up and talk to us about this new
program called sweep
uh since um
this came to fiscal and there had not
been any
previous discussion about what the uh
object of this program was
uh
some of the committee wanted to know
what we were trying to do sure so if we
could
thank you madam chair for the for the
opportunity so sweep and admittedly
we're running out of acronyms so I
apologize for that
um sweep is designed as an initiative
within the executive branch some time
ago really to identify technology and
other equipment Investments That might
be made in order to address efficient
system efficiencies and Workforce
efficiencies within state agencies
for that reason it was never really sort
of a single item like we bring typically
it says this is you know one big item
with a whole bunch of uh awards that are
going to be made underneath it this is
uh an initiative that we have been
involved with from to the extent of
reviewing uh
um um
requests from different state agencies
looking at them from the standpoint of
Eligibility under arpa and then
um determining which within those sort
of fit the uh the loose categorization
that we set up for this initiative and
then if there are other funding sources
that might be more adequate for some of
these they were urged to pursue those so
what you have today is a series of
individual items from Individual
agencies each with their own individual
benefits
that are not necessarily part of a huge
huge program
but are connected in that one sort of
concept of improving efficiency and
addressing potential Workforce
challenges in different agencies by
using technology and equipment
I hope does that help I hope
are there questions uh representative
Edwards I think thank you madam chair um
Okay so
uh first of all everything that you said
just now makes perfect sense I I think
it's a good initiative
I want to get to a layer or two deeper
though
and because there are so many
separate projects taking place under
this sweep umbrella
and they all generally have a similar
objective of leveraging the technology
to save Manpower
it seems to me that there may be a need
or or or benefit to having an identified
program manager who
crosswalks the executive branch to make
sure that these these projects are being
done in a an appropriate way that
there's metrics being established that
we're going to capture the Manpower
savings from anything we do that
somebody who really understands business
process re-engineering the the the
threat of applying technology to fixed
Manpower problems is that somebody's
gonna may try to just substitute
technology for people instead of
redesigning the underlying workflow so
so my concerns are kind of at the
Tactical level to make sure that we have
a competent program manager identified
who can crosswalk all of this and ensure
the best practices of business process
re-engineering are being used
uh thank you representative I would say
you know gopher has not relinquished any
of the role that it plays for any of
these arpa srf funds in terms of making
sure that there is compliance with the
Federal
requirements that we are tasked with
making for all of these programs and as
such you know these are categorized
within expenditure categories that each
have with within those their own
requirements so on that level we are
absolutely continuing to be engaged as
we are with all programs that come
before you that are funded for sfrf and
work with those agencies to make sure
that they are meeting those requirements
in terms of specific outcomes I will say
that you know as it relates to this
initiative called sweep we don't have
anything in place right now that would
capture that sort of thing across the
different agencies just exclusively
because you know there are some
significant differences in the types and
then the goals of these types of
programs
um I'm not saying it's not a good idea
I'm just saying at this point we are we
don't have that um plan in place
necessary to capture it now individual
agencies
um as they get this these resources
um would be you know should be able to
be uh determine what those outcomes are
um along the lines of what your of what
you're describing as individual agencies
follow-up so I have absolutely no
concern about us being able to spend
Federal money so that we're checking the
right box okay I'm I'm all about the
second part of your response which is
how do we ensure the outcomes are really
good because this is a huge investment
it's at least a significant investment
and we really would like to see those
positive outcomes I'm just concerned
that the decentralized nature of this uh
in non-existent organizational structure
we're not making sure that we have the
right subject matter expertise spread
across all the Departments and and and
if we want in the future to be able to
say okay we just spent 14 million
dollars or whatever the total is would
you please explain to us uh how that
impacted our our Manpower requirements I
I don't know that there would be a
unified reporting structure under the
current decentralized approach so so
it's the outcomes and the subject matter
expertise to ensure that we invest this
money really smartly
so so but I I think I've heard you you
don't have a centralized program
management function at this point but
maybe it's an idea that you'll think
about absolutely and and you know that
to the extent that we can work with the
agencies to identify at least a key a
couple of key indicators along the lines
of what you're referring to we would we
well uh thank you for that and and so if
you if you haven't want to have informal
ongoing conversations it's a topic that
I I did a little bit of at Phillips
Medical Systems I'd be happy to I'd
welcome that representative all right
let me follow up with you thank you
are there any further questions yes
Senator Daniels
I would have thought and I I would have
hoped that in the job description of our
employees the pursuit of efficiency
would have been an ongoing thing
so I question I understand your
statement about that we don't have a
centralized one but
um
are we not trying to find efficiencies
within a normal job description as
um well I can speak to the extent around
the different initiatives under sweep
which are the goal of the program really
as as we said is for agencies to have
identified where they feel that they
could make some substantial improvements
in the sufficiencies for it for any
given system with an investment of
technology or equipment it's not neces
it's not designed to displace any
existing employees it's not designed to
you know displace any existing Workforce
it's designed to improve efficiencies so
um to you know as as it relates to
individual job descriptions and how
those are constructed I don't really
have a lot of say over that in different
thank you
grab Senator Rosenwald thank you madam
chair on it different but go for issue
um if if I could
the Department of Health and Human
Services has done a fantastic job
planning for the end of the public
health emergency when
automatic continuous enrollment in
Medicaid will will end and people will
have to be redetermined or
um lose Medicaid what are we doing to
plan for the end of the emergency rental
assistance program in advance of I don't
even know when that's going to be but my
concern is about the the clients and the
local welfare budgets which might be
overwhelmed at the end of it if there is
not
thoughtful plan follow
wind down action what what are we doing
yes ma'am well we're obviously very
close contact with HHS and with New
Hampshire Housing and others as we go
through this we have a number of
outstanding requests from the United
States Treasury for additional funds
under era1 and era2 we received
information from treasury just I guess
it was earlier this week indicating that
they would let us know in a few days
whether there was going to be additional
resource available under the program
so we're continuing obviously to monitor
the amount of funding that's available
and how quickly that's being expended
with our partners at New Hampshire
housing but yeah I mean we're all
obviously very tuned into that issue
right now
follow-up thank you so with some of that
additional funding be used to create
um a wind down process or is it
there would be additional funding if we
got additional funding we would we would
absolutely be able to put some of that
into extending the services that are
available for people as we come towards
the uh the the end of the program so
that would be part of our plan okay
thank you yes
Senator Daniels thank you
um there there are three programs that
that have been outlined here uh with a
statement that no federal funds will be
sought
for that uh as far as the ongoing cost
after those systems are put in place
there's always an ongoing cost whether
it's maintenance for software or
whatever so what can we expect to see in
the budget to support these systems that
you are putting in place going forward
it would be really hard for me to say
senator you know because these are
individual agency items uh the language
that you're referring to we would hold
to that there would be no more resource
made available under arpa for these
types of programs uh I think they're
designed and submitted in such a fashion
that the resources that they've
requested under each of these individual
items would be sufficient to complete
the program I mean these are in most
cases Capital Investments uh
infrastructure type Investments not
operational so
um I think that that question probably
would be best asked of the individual
agencies given the those are the the
submitters of those items
okay thank you
representative
thank you madam chair uh thanks for what
you've given us already for information
but I guess in a follow-up to Senator
rosenwald's question the LBA has
prepared a document for us that they
give us every month showing how much
Federal money we've received over the
last biennium
and as you know it's over two billion
dollars
have you you talk about well we're
looking to get more federal funds into
the program but have you prepared
something for the governor or anybody
that what if none of this money is
forthcoming the state's going to have a
huge hole to fill because this money is
going to stop as we all know so have you
prepared anything to warn us or give us
uh
the information we need going forward
with the loss of these federal funds
well I mean I would say first off I mean
with regard to the 2 billion and I think
probably in the end that number is
actually higher than that if you include
cares act it's a substantial amount of
money obviously it's all been pretty
heavily bucketed particularly under the
arpa funds into many different types of
buckets so even within the era program
and in the housing assistance program we
have era1 era2 and the housing
assistance fund Each of which have their
own set of rules as to how you can spend
that money so the challenge that we have
continuously had and I've tried to you
know
illustrate is that due to the fact that
each of these have their own rules and
each of them have different funding
timelines each of them have
outstanding requests of differing
amounts of money and we're not able to
know from the federal government when
they're going to provide any additional
resources while we do monitor obviously
all of the funds that are available it's
difficult to say you know this is these
are the specific deadlines that we're
facing right now so
yeah we've done a good deal of work with
New Hampshire housing at trying to
predict when this outcome is coming but
again because we don't have really
solid numbers and timelines it's hard
for us to say yes it's going to be on
this date and when we get that we'll be
able to do that I would imagine pretty
quickly based on what we have available
so I guess I'm concerned you say you
don't have the availability because you
don't know when these timelines are
going to end so you're saying the
federal government has not been
forthcoming whether these programs will
be extended or like I think we saw
recently 40 million dollars for rental
assistance if that ends
there are going to be a lot of people
either out of the street or landlords
not getting paid I guess I'm concerned
that
we should have something more to prepare
us for what I think may be difficult
times ahead because this money is going
to end right and so there are deadlines
on when we can spend the money so era
one if we get additional funding under
that we're going to have to spend that
by December 30th if we get additional
funding on under era2 we have a longer
time Horizon I believe out until 2023 or
4 5 for that for that funding and in
addition as I mentioned to Senator
Rosenwald we're going to add more
funding under those programs assuming
that we do get some to continue the
support services that have been ongoing
already with people that are receiving
funds under this program it's not like
they're just getting this money and
they're sitting in their in their rooms
we're working with them to be able to
continue to transition them off of the
need for the assistance and New
Hampshire Housing and the Caps have been
doing a great job at maintaining that
constant sort of churn so
um I know it we certainly would love to
be able to say that there is a
definitive point at which we're going to
need to start thinking about how are we
going to transition people we are the
fact is that we're constantly
transitioning people and that as soon as
we're able to have some sort of sense as
to when we're going to see any
additional funding or not then we'll
make plans obviously based on that
information thanks thanks Venom chair
representative Edwards uh you thank you
madam chair I just want to weave
together my earlier comments with what
Senator Daniels added that on all of
these I.T systems many places it says
this is a one-time investment and I
think we should know that whenever you
invest in I.T in the olden days or you
had to budget like 18 percent of the
acquisition cost every year for for for
maintenance so it's it's not a one-time
expense it's a commitment to a forever
stream of expenses maybe as much as 18
of the acquisition costs and then
someday you got to replace it so so so
because there's real money going out as
far as the eye can see on these on these
I.T investments in particular I just
really think it's important for us to go
into this initiative ensuring that we
are
influencing and reducing our demands on
Manpower hour
otherwise the money to pay for this
eighteen percent is going to have to
become incremental and that's and that's
where the bad budget outcome gets to be
so I I I want to I just wanted to make
that point that it's really important
that we uh do these programs right
because we're going we're going to need
to find the money to sustain them yeah
no I agree and that is the intent of the
program is to make these as close to
one-time Investments as we can in fact
as you've heard me say before in almost
every one of the programs that we bring
under sfrf that's sort of the the one of
the main one of the main points that
we're we're trying to stick to in the
types of items that we're bringing is
that these are one-time Investments for
foreign
thank you very much okay thank you
um
we conveniently took uh FIS 22 351 off
the uh consent calendar
in order to hear what the Gopher office
had to say about these programs
so could I have a motion to ex thank you
Senator Bradley do I have a second
second Senator Susie
Madam chair can you please uh explain
what the motion is oh we're going to
roll call on 351. representative Edwards
uh on 351 yes Hamrick votes yes
representative erf yes representative
leishman yes Senator Daniels yes Senator
Bradley Senator gray yes Senator
Rosenwald yes Senator Susie
representative umberger yes Madam chair
the voters 10 to nothing the vote being
we now go to um
FIS 22 359.
Governors uh authorization to accept and
expend 20 million 22 503 dollars
in srf funds
uh I believe that someone in the senate
is there any
pardon
oh okay
all right so no questions all right I
thought there were questions dealing
with how the community centers were
going to uh get word of this spot okay
so uh
Senator Rosenwald moves 22-359
roll call on 359. the museum Edwards yes
to 359 Emrick votes yes representative
erf yes representative leishman yes
Senator Daniels yes Senator Bradley yes
Senator gray yes Senator Rosenwald yes
Senator Susie represent umberger yes I
am sure the vote is ten to zero the vote
being 10-0 FIS 22 359 is approved
which is a request for 8 million
dollars
Madam chair yes
um
somewhere in here I think we agreed to
bring forward the information item on
vaccines and uh if we're talking about
361 now then I think we maybe want to
I think we're confused what would you
like to hear first 361 or the
informational item the informational
changing chairs is always fun it's okay
this is a great time thank you
foreign
apology is a little musical chairs there
uh so Madam chair members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to come before you this morning to talk
about uh I think the important issue of
covid-19 vaccinations uh for the record
my name is uh Ben Shan I am the state
epidemiologist at the New Hampshire
Department of Health and Human Services
could you pull your microphone closer
please oh I'm apologizing that's okay um
just uh saying that I am the state
epidemiologist at the New Hampshire
Department of Health and Human Services
uh also on infectious disease internal
medicine and preventive medicine
physician uh several weeks ago I got a
request I believe some from some members
of this committee wanting to know um
more about the science and specifically
the scientific studies that have been
used to back up covid-19 vaccine
recommendations and so over the ensuing
couple of weeks I developed this um
three and a half four page New Hampshire
science brief about the safety and
effectiveness of covid-19 mRNA vaccines
I understand that the request was
primarily focused on uh data for
children but I did include in the
science brief uh all data that we have
been reviewing over the course of the
pandemic for children adolescents and
adults uh partly because that data is
important uh for informing also what uh
you know for the seeing the consistent
Trends in vaccine safety and
Effectiveness and all data has been used
to inform covid-19 vaccine
recommendations and so while this looks
like a long report the actual text the
actual science brief of it is only about
three and a half pages the rest are
scientific references pointing to
peer-reviewed journal Publications in
reputable scientific journals I did not
include any pre-print Publications which
are studies that have been written but
have not yet gone through the scientific
review process by
peer reviewers and editors and so this
scientific brief really focuses on those
um reputable scientific journal
Publications that have come out around
vaccine safety and Effectiveness over
the last couple of years of the pandemic
since we've had covid-19 vaccines
available so I believe this has been
circulated ahead of time but I wanted to
be available to answer questions you may
have about this science brief that we
developed or questions about covid-19
vaccines in general
thank you
uh thank you your paper was very good
probably some folks didn't agree with
your conclusions but that's the way it's
been with covid-19 and uh
science or whatever so don't
um
it's okay we we all in this case there
are many different opinions but I
believe representative Edwards you had
some questions for Dr Chen uh I I do
Madam chair and I'm not just just to
clarify my questions are related to you
know the processes that we use within
the public health department I'm not
challenging the conclusions of of Dr
Chan I I just want to make sure that the
public confidence is inspired by the
outstanding clinical research
capabilities we have in the department
and so in order to highlight them I have
maybe maybe about five questions or so
um I
I think what people heard when they
heard the saying that we should be
following the science what they thought
that meant was that there would be good
clinical research done before a policy
governmental policy mandate was imposed
and I think a lot of people got
concerned because of the perception that
we weren't following the science we were
sort of reacting to the instincts of a
select number of scientific people so so
so I really am very glad that I that
you've come out with this paper because
I think this is a sort of the first time
we've put a stake in the ground saying
here's the science and this is this is
and therefore this is our policy would
you agree or disagree would you say it
differently yeah um thank you for that
question representative Edwards because
I think it's an important point to make
is that
um we never and have never throughout
this pandemic just accepted
recommendations coming from from the
federal government and particularly
around when it comes to medical
recommendations
um one one of the the key roles of
myself and and several other clinicians
in the in the department is to review
the science ourselves and so that's what
we've done and so the the compilation of
the science memo actually is from uh
studies that we have collected and
reviewed in New Hampshire are studying
and looking at and reviewing the studies
that have come out around vaccine
science and the safety and the
effectiveness of the covid-19 vaccines
so that's where these 120 plus
references came from these are all
studies that we have reviewed over the
course of this pandemic
um and have have been used to inform our
you know adoption and support for a lot
of the covid-19 vaccine recommendations
that are out there but you know this
this applies to other areas of covid-19
response as well not just covid-19
vaccines we've always reviewed the
science and have uh which has informed
our approach that has sometimes deviated
from you know Federal guidance on on a
number of matters but when it comes to
covid-19 vaccines I think the the data
and the science is overwhelmingly clear
multiple studies as I highlighted in
this report that the vaccines are safe
even for children and to maintain High
Effectiveness particularly against more
severe disease and also long-term
complications of 19 which I also
highlight in the in the science brief
the the only other point I wanted to
make is that at a federal level I think
people need to be aware that it's not
just
um Federal politicians or bureaucrats so
to speak or federal employees I should
say that are coming out with these
guidelines and recommendations
particularly when it comes to vaccine
recommendations and this is one of the
key roles of the what we call acip the
advisory committee on immunization
practices which helps to create all of
the recommendations for all childhood
vaccination series these are not federal
employees these are a group of medical
professionals people with expertise and
vaccines who come together to review the
science and to make determinations and
make recommendations about vaccine
recommendations you know it's it's a
medical group so the the acip
supports the federal guidance that comes
out helps to develop that Federal
guidance so it's not just federal
employees or federal politicians that
are coming out with the guidance at a
federal level but certainly at a local
level we we take our responsibility for
similarly reviewing the guidance um
seriously similar to what the the acip
does at a federal level
so so
um would you agree that any of these
studies should be subject to a
scientific method and and what I
consider the scientific method and you
could educate me if I'm wrong
is that a hypothesis gets identified a
research trial is put together the data
is gathered and analyzed and and the key
to good scientific inquiry is repeat
repeatability
and uh and and with repeatability comes
the uh a power or the opportunity to
refute and disagree with the results to
to to challenge the scientific inquiry
process would would you describe would
you agree or say it different about the
scientific method yeah I think the
scientific method has been proven over
and over again to be important and
reliable and part of that is defining
defining what you're studying and then
the study outcomes and that does need to
be repeatable and so I think what we
have seen with the kova 19 vaccine
literature the scientific Publications
is you know and I tried to highlight
this in the science brief over and over
again multiple Studies have found
consistent findings both between adult
adults and children and across multiple
studies of repeatable findings that
these vaccines are are safe and
effective I I will also say that there
are differences in quality of studies so
it's not just about any one particular
study it's about the type of study is it
a randomized double-blinded
placebo-controlled clinical trial or is
it what we call a higher level
ecological study that has um usually we
have lower confidence in findings of
studies that are not well designed or
not as rigorous so so this highlights I
think the importance not only of the
study and study design pain but also to
what you say is that the repeatability
um well thank you for that so
um
so that takes me to the the Florida
question which is
um evidently I'm a Layman I've worked
around you know academics so I kind of
understand what they've done but I I've
only been a poor role but but as I've as
I've taken a look at what Florida is
coming up with and the kind of
guidelines they're coming up with with
the the the demographics of uh kids six
months and older the demographics
between I don't know if it's five to
eleven or five to Seventeen I forget the
end point and then even recently they
said men ages 18 to 39 that none of
those three demographic groups really
ought to be thrown into the category of
default taking of the the coven shot and
because their conclusion is so much
different than our own in 361 we we make
a very categorical statement
um on on page three that the Department
recommends that all persons six months
of age or older complete the covid-19
primary series and boost your
vaccination when eligible
so so our conclusion is very strong very
strong and very different than Florida
and so can you can you explain you know
the extent to which you you look at
contrary opinions and you use it to you
know second guess yourself not so that
people like me aren't second-guessing
you but that you've got your own process
yeah um representative thanks for that
question and I think it's an important
um point an important question to make
because there has been a lot of
confusion
um you know and I think there's been
multiple instances where I think the
public uh in general even providers have
been confused because of differing
recommendations coming out from
different states throughout the pandemic
not not related necessarily to covid-19
vaccines
um I will say that when it when it comes
to kova 19 vaccine recommendations
um you know I am aware of Florida's
guidance it was sent to me ahead of this
meeting so I did have a chance to review
it particularly for their guidance for
Pediatric vaccines which I have in front
of me here I printed it out there in the
minority I I am not uh I my
understanding is that the vast majority
of other public health jurisdictions
across the state across the country
um are in alignment and in agreement
with the the guidance and the
recommendations that have come out from
the CDC and acip the advisory committee
on immunization practices and it's not
just adopting these guidelines from the
fed from the feds by default there's
there's science to back it up when I
looked at Florida's guidance you know my
concern is that this is not appropriate
guidance uh it's not appropriate medical
guidance because it's not evidence-based
guidance
um you know they they reference several
studies in their guidance but if you
actually click on those studies and go
into review and see what those studies
are actually saying those studies are
not actually supporting their
conclusions and so this guidance is my
opinion not evidence-based and it's not
backed up by the vast majority of the
science out there which has shown
vaccines repeatedly to be safe and
effective and the conclusions that
they're drawing from some of the studies
that are linked in their guidance are
not are not actually are is just simply
not appropriating so just as an example
um one of their points uh in which they
sort of come out less strongly if I can
put it that way against covid-19
vaccines and kids they talk at one of
their bullet points here is limited risk
of severe illness due to covid-19 in
children and they reference a study but
that's not actually what the study is
studying if you click on the link the
the study that they reference is about
the evaluation of the Pfizer vaccine in
children 5 to 11 years of age so so you
can't actually draw that conclusion from
the study that is referenced in order to
look at severe illness from covid-19 in
children you need to study this design
to look at severe illness in children
and not studying vaccine Effectiveness
in children and actually that studies
conclusions are that the Pfizer vaccine
in children is found to be safe
immunogenetic
immunogenic and efficacious in children
5 to 11 to 11 years of age so so that's
just one example where I don't think
that Florida's guidance is is
evidence-based or appropriate based on
what their what they're referencing here
for studies so just to clarify somebody
May misinterpret your initial couple of
sentences to imply that its majority
rules on science and I don't think you
meant to say that at all you just gave
us an extremely long explanation of the
body of the evidence and the number of
you know repeat examples so I just I
just didn't want you misunderstood about
majority rules on scientific issues now
uh earlier today I had a chance to chat
with Dr Ballard and and Ms Tilly and
they they pointed out multiple instances
where the department
has differed in its opinions from what
the CDC was promulgating and uh and I I
think that's kind of an interesting
topic because it may help demonstrate
sort of the independence of thought and
the thoroughness of of what we're
investing into the process can you can
you maybe give us an example and and
talk about uh you know sort of New
Hampshire as as an independent thought
leader in this area yeah thanks for that
question would you like examples just
related to covid-19 vaccines or other
examples let's stay on topic just and if
you got a six-month-old example that
would be really great but you probably
don't yeah um you know thank you thank
you for that uh thank you for that for
that question and I think there have
been multiple examples throughout the
pandemic where we've differed
um or come out with our own guidance all
throughout the pandemic um either
because it the guidance wasn't there at
a federal level or it wasn't there on
time or we disagreed with it
um you know relative to vaccines you
know I think there are a number of
instances
throughout the last you know two years
of the the pandemic maybe the first
example I'll point to is going back to
January of 2021 if I can go back that
far in my memory when vaccines had just
started to roll out
um and uh we had focused vaccines for
those at highest risk for severe disease
and older adults who me um and excuse me
and Health Care Health Care workers who
are on the front lines
um and just one example of applying
vaccine science to our guidance there
was an intense discussion come January
about whether we were going to still
require people who were fully vaccinated
who had gotten the primary series to
quarantine after an exposure
and we in New Hampshire were pushing
hard for that for the federal government
to take the step of not you know
recommending quarantine for people who
are fully vaccinated to quarantine for a
few reasons one because the data at that
time was showing that the vaccines were
highly effective at preventing disease
like 94 95 percent effective at
preventing disease keys and with a
vaccine that that's that effective we
didn't see a need to still you know
require people to quarantine we were
actually one of the first states in the
country
um to come out and make the
recommendation that people who are fully
vaccinated were not required to
quarantine after an exposure
um and it took the the federal
government the CDC one to two months
longer to come out with that
recommendation
um for for whatever reason I can't speak
to exactly you know we were having
discussions with CDC about the time
around about this around the time but
that that was one of the earliest
examples of you know we were looking at
the vaccine science and the vaccine data
and using it to inform our approach and
recommendations
um one of the early earliest of which
was not requiring people to quarantine
after an exposure
um they were right around the time a
vaccine rollout the federal government
was coming out with guidance about who
should get vaccinated first
um particularly with limited vaccine you
know New Hampshire as with many other
states you know came up with our own
strategy we had a whole team working on
that vaccine allocation strategy
more more recently with the the rollout
of the Omicron boosters we have uh we
have so the recommendation now is that
as long as somebody is at least two
months and this is a little bit of a
detail that maybe is not that important
but highlights the example the
recommendation has been that people who
are at least two months out since their
last dose of the vaccine
the older version of the vaccine are
eligible for one of these updated
Omicron boosters
um that that's a p a detail in the
recommendation that I generally don't
agree with I think that's too short of a
time frame I don't think there's a
safety concern with somebody getting
vaccinated two months after their last
dose I just think it's unnecessary and
it doesn't optimize the effectiveness of
the vaccine and so we we have put out
guidance in some of our health alert
Network messages and publicly suggesting
that people wait you know a longer
period of time between infection or
prior vaccination and getting one of the
updated Omicron boosters in order to
optimize
the protective effect of these updated
booster doses so those are just a few
examples
um you know some some more pertinent and
all right um so so we're spending a lot
of time in a fiscal committee on this
but I I think I think it's I think it's
worthwhile because we're coming out of
two and a half
years of the pandemic and this is really
the first example that I can recall
where we've we've published the science
to the public and said our policy is
supported by the science we're sharing
with you which I hope in the after
action review is annotated as something
for the future that we we are more
proactive in getting the science put in
front of the public so they can
understand any of the policies we're
implementing so so with all of
everything you've said I my concern is
still on page three of 361 and there's a
particular sentence in there that I just
want to make sure that you you agree and
support it and I think Miss Tilly can
stick your your finger on it the the the
New Hampshire Department of Health and
Human Services
recommends that all persons six months
of age or older complete the covid-19
primary series and booster vaccination
when eligible a reformulated booster
which is currently available to
individuals 12 years of age or older
will offer enhanced protection against
covid-19 is is this is this possibly an
over promise a too strong a
recommendation or do you stand by this
literally
can I can I see the wording again since
you're asking about literal
um
what what uh is there a specific section
there that you are concerned about well
it's I I I just read it it's from page
three of um 361 down underneath the
table underneath the term vaccination
and testing services there's a two
sentence paragraph yeah so so so yes I
think we we stand We Stand by that
recommendation
um you know certainly there are a uh
some minority of people
them that may not be eligible to get the
vaccine because of a medical
contraindication
certainly those people shouldn't be
vaccinated and there's there's guidance
for who shouldn't get vaccinated
um but but everybody else
um you know it continues to be our
recommendation that everybody else six
months of age and older be vaccinated
now I I do want to acknowledge that
certainly children are at lower risk for
severe disease severe outcomes from
covid-19 but it's not true that they're
at no risk and so I think that the the
data even in children consistently shows
that vaccine even in otherwise healthy
children
vaccine offers important protection
against covid-19 against kova 19 in the
short term we're talking over several
months
um over protection against severe
disease in the longer term and then
potentially you know protection against
some of the longer term complications
that that can arise from covet 19. I
mean we're we're seeing more and more
studies come out for example showing an
association between covid-19 disease
covid-19 infection and diabetes right I
mean diabetes is a lifelong medical
complication now we can't predict who's
going to come down with complications of
covid-19 right some people will get
covid-19 and have very mild illness and
get over it have no problems other
people can have covid-19 children
included develop multi-system
inflammatory syndrome end up in the
hospital die get long coveted develop
diabetes certainly that the risk of that
happening in children is lower but we
can't predict uh who who's going to
develop those complications and who
isn't
um and the the data in adults in
adolescents and children has been clear
that the vaccines are safe the vaccines
are effective and that um uh any any you
know potential side effects from the
vaccines are usually short-lived due to
the body's reaction to the vaccine uh
and that the the benefits of vaccination
even in children outweigh
um potential side effects
uh thank you madam chair and uh thank
you Dr Chan and your colleagues for your
service to the state I appreciate you uh
working on this so hard and sharing it
with us thanks my pleasure thank you for
your questions
are there any further questions uh
Senator Bradley
foreign
thank you very much so going back to
what you told the Health and Human
Services committee several months ago Ms
Tilly
um obviously the department recommends
but there is
no initiative on the Department's part
to go forward with the gel Car
application to require a vaccine for
school-aged children or children
attending daycare is that still correct
thank you Senator Bradley that is
correct we are not moving forward with
any recommendation for mandatory vaccine
for covid-19 for school or Child Care
entry
thank you
can I um I'm sorry madam chair and if I
can also comment um there there was a I
forget the the committee that um this
question has come up at about
um School School requirements for
vaccines that uh I think we we had a
similar discussion at
um I just wanted to add uh to what
director Tilly said that that the
Covenant it's looking like the covid-19
vaccine will turn into probably an
annual booster right I mean I mean the
the science the data is still out on
that
um but it's not the type of vaccine
which we would require or add to the
required list for childhood vaccination
series for entry into school or child
care because because partly because
we're expecting it to turn into an
annual vaccine just like we don't
require the flu vaccine every year
there's no plans at this point to add
the covid-19 vaccine which is looking
like it's going to be an annual vaccine
to the required list
um both both because of you know the
properties of of That vaccine and just
the logistical hurdles of trying to you
know have a school verify a child a
student is vaccinated every year is just
Senator Daniels
thank you uh Dr Chen on the references
that you provide of the 125 references
are they all supportive of your position
or are there some in there that are
um well so the the the references are
linked to specific statements throughout
the document and so those those
references are supportive of the
statements that are made throughout the
document that the references are are
linked to
um you know I I think the the overall
conclusion also of those studies
um is uh it is supportive of what I've
okay I'm not sure you answered the
question so in in the references that
you provided here they are supportive of
your statement the same vaccines are
safe and effective my question is are
there studies that you looked at
that you have included in this list that
um I I would have to pull up specific
studies but
um I'm trying to think back through the
studies
um
no I think I think the studies are all
particularly around vaccine safety are
all supportive of that statement
okay thank you and uh if you if you have
a specific example that you're that you
find I'm happy to sort of review or talk
through that study but you know again
it's it's
pulling from my memory here well I think
the chair started out by saying that
people have very various opinions
on on vaccines so you know I wondered if
you know we're looking at a paper that's
got 125 references that are basically
going to be lopsided versus there may be
other studies in there that have an
opinion that is contrary to the
statement that they are safe and
effective uh for instance uh you know
how do you explain to someone whose
child uh has had adverse effects by
having a vaccine even to the point of
Dying by telling them that it's safe and
effective yeah and and thanks for asking
that question because I think it is
important to separate science and
studies from opinion
um and so I certainly recognize the fact
that different people have different
opinions
um but but again I think the the the
data here supports vaccines being being
safe you know I know that the question
of um uh well I think partly this comes
back to the the some of the Florida
guidance that was out in the news
recently where they did a very high
level crude analysis of some of their
their death data which I think
inappropriately suggested
um that there was a higher rate of death
after vaccination
um and again this is this is where it's
important to sort of look at the study
and look at the science behind it
because that that report is not the kind
of data that would I think ever get
published or make its way into a
scientific journal just because of all
the problems behind that analysis when
it comes to
um when it comes to questions of
covid-19 vaccines and safety
um what what I will say and what we have
said all along is that there there are
not there's not evidence of some excess
number of deaths related to vaccines
that that I that I've seen now there are
people suggesting that but I don't think
that that's backed by science or data
and in fact any death that occurs after
vaccination for whatever the cause is
required to be reported into theirs
which then gets investigated further
um and so it's it's not just about doing
you know high level you know medical
record system analysis uh it's it's
really about diving in to understand the
cause of death
um and what's what's been found in
reviewing that data is that you know
people that are reportedly dying after
vaccination are not dying from you know
the vaccine themselves a vast majority
of them are getting vaccinated and then
dying from other causes or even covid-19
itself so a lot of those a lot of the uh
wrong information that's out there about
all these deaths from vaccine or not not
actually deaths from vaccines themselves
that's that's data that is
um that is poor quality data or data
that's being misrepresented or
misinterpreted to back someone's opinion
or concern
yeah how will we how are we supposed to
uh believe in scientific data and I'll
use your point because it was uh right
on where particularly uh we saw
individuals in nursing homes that had
comorbidities uh
that came down with covet there their
death certificate revealed that the
death was coveted not the other so you
know the we I think there's a certain
number of people who believe that those
numbers were skewed to make it seem like
uh covered was worse than it was uh
versus uh having the comorbidity so you
know how are we as legislators supposed
to
understand and believe what is actually
the truth yeah another another great
question I think your your concern gets
that the question of how we conduct how
we conduct death surveillance
particularly around coven 19.
um and that this is I think another area
of confusion because different states
have done it different ways all
throughout the pandemic and you've heard
reports coming out from other states you
know I I will say that um in New
Hampshire I can speak for New Hampshire
um we rely on the death certificate
um the the death certificate is a formal
objective way of assessing deaths from
any disease it also relies on the health
care provider who's pronouncing the
person as having died a health care
provider assessment as to the cause of
death
um and so we're not the the public
health agency the New Hampshire uh
Department of Health and Human Services
is not the agency that's you know
vetting and assessing whether somebody
died or not from disease a or disease X
or covid-19 we're relying on that
healthcare provider assessment to help
make that determination and not only
that assessment but that assessment as
documented in the death record and so if
anything at least in New Hampshire our
our assessment of covid-19 related
deaths is likely an under assessment now
other states have done it different ways
which has been in the media over the
course of the pandemic with people
voicing concerns about overestimating
covid-19 related deaths but that's not
the case in New Hampshire we've always
taken a much more conservative approach
to classifying covid-19 related deaths
it's very similar to how we track other
um other deaths from other diseases like
influenza and so again I think we've
we've tried to come up with a process
that is relies on the existing systems
we have in place similar to how we track
other you know infectious disease
related deaths and relies ultimately on
that health care provider assessment as
to the cause of death
command of a chair
Senator Rosenwald thank you my questions
are about the Telehealth part of this
item
um
I'm trying to understand
the process of how this works so if I do
a home test
and it's positive am I able to then
access this Telehealth program
and it's my insurance going to cover the
cost of the Pax clavid sure if I'm
eligible or is the money where
appropriating today going to pay for
that and my insurance company won't be
billed or do I have to go somewhere and
get a PCR test
great thank you very much for that
question Senator Rosenwald so we are
envisioning this program similar to a
program that was done in Massachusetts
so again I'm home I'm sick I have a
rapid antigen test I test positive I may
be at risk for poor outcomes so you can
call the tell this entity we will put a
contract through that will go through
governor and Council for a health care
entity who will be available 24 maybe
not 24 7 but certainly seven days a week
to be able to take you in and do a
medical evaluation and look at your your
tests that you tested positive they may
ask you to take another test but I think
they will document you know you show up
yep I tested positive and they'll go
through and ask several questions and
assess whether or not pacslovid or
another therapeutic is right for you
um assuming it is they will have two
options one they could send that
directly into your Pharmacy so if I go
to my Colonial Pharmacy in New London
New Hampshire they can send that script
in and I can have someone go and pick it
up for me if that won't work for me
because I'm homebound or I don't have
anyone to go out to the pharmacy for me
we can arrange for it to be overnight
shipped directly to your home the
question around insurance is an
interesting one because the at the
federal level
um currently pacslovit is covered it is
by the federal government so it is free
at this moment that may change in the
future and we want to build in
flexibility within the contract to
ensure that we can cover that for an
uninsured person we want to make sure
that these the Telehealth visits are
available to anyone appropriate 18 and
over
um and have it to be free and no cost to
them is there anything you'd like to add
Dr Ballard
no that's very accurate and so Jonathan
Ballard chief medical officer for the
Department
um So currently the peck slope it is
being directly provided to pharmacies
from the federal government and so when
you get it uh you they Pharmacy May
charge a dispensing fee potentially
they're allowed to but there's no charge
for the drug itself
also the federal government has provided
the Department of Health and Human
Services in New Hampshire a supply of
pacslova that we will provide to the
contracted vendor for the medication
that would be directly shipped or
um so
this sounds like it's a money saver
because if I do a home test I don't have
to go to one of those for profit urgent
care centers that are going to do a
whole work up and charge me
a big co-pay and a co-insurance to make
sure I don't have anything else going on
right absolutely no charge for using
that Telehealth no charge for using the
Telehealth and I think that that's one
of the benefits of this program again as
we get through this winter surge I have
shared my personal story I had covid
recently and when I called my primary
care physician they said go to the
emergency room I was actually feeling so
poorly I did not want to go to the
emergency room and again
Urgent Care said come on in I didn't
feel like that was the right path for me
I waited until I could go to a pharmacy
that also has a federal program called
test to treat but really not many people
know about that and it's really
complicated so we want to make this
easier for people especially in rural
areas especially people who may not have
a strong relationship with a primary
care provider who tests positive on a
Saturday morning and don't want to wait
several days and and finally I mean I
think this sounds like one of the best
ideas I've heard in a long time thank
you for doing it
um
when will this program be up and running
and how how are the 1.4 million people
in New Hampshire supposed to know about
it
a couple of components to that
so we will identify we're in procurement
process with a potential vendor it will
go to governor and Council very soon
whenever it is ex performed with
government Council we fully expect that
this type of a program with a potential
vendor would be implemented very fast
now some programs like Staffing surges
and those take time to pull to implement
but this is not something that will take
an enormous amount of time to implement
it would be within weeks or days of the
governor and council meeting and if I
just may add
uh the
the
Investments that this committee has made
over the last couple of years these very
targeted projects like this I think is
what distinguished New Hampshire as well
and so much so much of our good response
um there was Senator Daniels has asked
in the past for us to bring data back
when we bring programs forth like this
to say you know to justify what we've
done in the past and these types of
programs uh there was a recent report
from the Commonwealth Fund in June of
2022 that looked at throughout 2021 and
20 up until March of 2022 all the states
and the amount of excess deaths that
each state encountered from all causes
including covid and there was only one
state that had less excess deaths than
New Hampshire and it was Hawaii but we
had the second least excess deaths from
covid from opioid overdoses from chronic
disease deaths compared to any other
state and I brought that along with you
just so you know that these types of
Target Investments that we've done one
not positive but suggestive have made a
difference
and to follow up the last part of how
will people know it is built into the
contract that they will have to do some
advertising and maximize that the vendor
itself will do advertising and we'll
certainly amplify that through the
department with through our
thank you madam chair my question is
more of curiosity rather than this
specific discussion about the vaccine I
was an early adopter
and got covered in 2020
took me out of the commission for about
three weeks and thankfully I lost 20
pounds which I've gained back but that's
a different story the problem I've had
the the issue I've had is there's been
no recognition of actually Contracting
the disease and your
uh protection you know it's it's like
devoid of any value that you actually
had covet and I'm just curious why why
isn't there anything that says below if
you've already had it maybe you only
need one booster instead of two or some
anything just some kind of recognition
right thank you representative Emrick so
that actually is something we do have in
our guidance and there's a time period
after having contracted kova 19 that we
actually say and Dr Chan referenced this
earlier that we would recommend delay
getting the booster vaccine until a time
period passed by Dr chance at 90 days 90
days 90 days and so after that time
period we'd actually do do recommend
that to wait that time period and then
get the vaccinations
because you're at less risk of
Contracting covet for those first 90
yeah okay
uh are there any are there any further
questions
okay uh Senator Bradley moves uh
seconded by Senator Rosenwald
will the clerk please call the roll on
361.
representative Edwards yes to 361. they
make votes yes Representative erf no
representative leishman yes
representative Daniels no
representative Bradley yes
representative gray yes
Reverend Rosenwald yes I'm sorry
Senators my apologies I was on a roll
with representative
uh Senator Rosenwald yes
Senator Susie
representative umberger yes
Madam chair the voice is eight yes and
two no okay the vote being eight in
favor and two opposed
FIS 22 361 passes
okay we now turn to oh by the way Dr
Chan thank you so much for your your
presentation and I believe that it has
uh provided a lot of really good
information to the committee as well as
to um anyone that might be watching it
on YouTube so thank you so much for that
authorization to expend 228
okay uh
representative Edwards thank you madam
chair hopefully this is more in the
lines of yes or no
um we're this looks like it's a request
to buy a particular form of a test and
it's specifically written up for covid
and I'm just curious if
um there are tests that would fall under
this sort of funding Authority that
would be more robust in its testing I
mean people used to die of flu are we
gonna are we going to use this or is
there anything we can buy that will test
for more than one thing
thank you representative Edwards for
that question so as the pandemic has
progressed new technology new
Therapeutics has emerged allow us to
mitigate the effects of it and this is
one development that we want to
implement for those persons that we
serve at our 24 7 facilities so a PCR
test is a test that is a you know a gold
standard type of test that that
um
is for both symptomatic and asymptomatic
persons now we have those tests that are
rapid on site that can be done at the at
the actual facility not having to be
sent off to a lab also now the tests are
available to be done through saliva
samples and not a nose nasal sample so
this is sort of the latest
uh you know latest thing that is FDA you
know emergency Authority authorized
approved and
what it can do for us is very unique
situations I was speaking with the
commandant of the New Hampshire veterans
home for when our when one of our
veterans uh May contract covid-19 and
they have a roommate who's asymptomatic
this will be a particular test that that
roommate can have that will be highly
accurate immediately allow her to make
the commandant to make those decisions
or whether or not that we need to to
move the patient to another room
and so uh there is no other flu vaccine
or anything or excuse me flu test that
is like this yet all of those tests have
to be done in a commercial laboratory so
this is sort of the latest technology
that's available but is not able to be
combined with other types of tests such
as testing for flu
okay that last sentence was what I was
looking for thank you
okay
Senator Daniels thank you over the over
the past few months or years we've spent
a lot of money putting it into testing
stuff what do we have for current
zero for this type of Technology uh this
is a this is a new type of technology
that allows us to make better decisions
for our veterans and other persons that
um uh it will benefit so we don't have
any any we have rapid antigen tests but
those take some time to to develop uh
positive results or negative results
after exposure to the virus so this will
be uh allow us to make decisions sooner
and we have zero supply of this okay
thank you
thank you uh representative valishman
moves uh item
uh yeah FIS 22 362. do I have a second
second by Senator Susie
will the clerk please call the roll roll
call on 362. representative Edwards yes
to 362. Hamrick votes yes representative
erf yes representative leishman yes
Senator Daniels yes Senator Bradley
oh I'm sorry he'll be back in just a
minute Senator gray yes
turn to Rosenwald yes Senator Susie
representative umberger yes
Madam chair the vote is nine to zero
the vote being nine to zero FIS
62 passes
or three
362. okay next FIS 22 363.
which is authorization to accept uh 750
000 dollars in
welcome
could you identify yourselves please
David Wieters Information Services
good morning Karen Hebert director of
the division of Economic and housing
stability
thank you
uh does anyone have any questions on
this
because I do I do okay
if no one else does I'll just ask my
questions
um
my concern is
when do we anticipate Medicaid
the great question so just yesterday
the secretary of the U.S Department of
Health and Human Services just uh
renewed The Declaration of the federal
Public Health Emergency for another 90
days so we are anticipating that it
could certainly end January 12th would
be that particular date we expect that
we would get notification of that from
the White House 60 days in advance of
that date so we're looking at hopefully
knowing more information by November
12th
um
the
continuous enrollment if it were to end
uh January 11th The Continuous
February 1st would be the first date
that coverage could be terminated
and then the enhanced fmap of 6.2
so if I understand what you just said we
have no clue
that's correct
okay
well I just thought I'd ask and uh
and how many people are currently
so that currently there's uh 243
238 individuals who need my glasses who
are enrolled in Medicaid and that's
individuals
the protected status the protected
number of individuals
and those are the individuals who are at
okay
that's all does anyone else have any
question representative Edwards
uh thank you madam chair so
um this is actually a good example of
the conversation I I was having earlier
with Miss or Caswell
uh that we're we're looking to use
technology to
um
make us more efficient and do with fewer
Manpower less Manpower so do we have the
skill sets to to go in and make sure
that we're not just substituting
technology that we're actually looking
at a redesign of workflow to leverage
the technical capacities or in other
words are are are we are we really going
to take advantage of the opportunity to
fundamentally improve the system
and by that I mean more than the I.T
system
certainly that's a good question
representative Edwards um so in
preparing for this item
the department in conjunction with the
incumbent vendor looked at the solution
that we're looking at for New Heights
and the goal is to use that funds to do
that business process management or
re-engineering to allow for the manual
processes to be replaced with the
automation this will allow those people
that would be otherwise impacted
pretty heavily by 95 000 people
potentially being losing their
eligibility to focus on providing the
services and providing the
continuous operations of the system if
we don't implement this solution the
staff would be overwhelmed with
potential eligibility Appeals so this is
really
to answer your question is part of that
business Process Management we
identified this is the only way we can
really address the potential Public
effectively
did that answer your question I I think
you brushed up against it
um I I'm I'm more concerned at this
point in the quality of the business
process re-engineering and whether or
not we have access to the skill sets if
if we think we're going to actually do a
redesign of the workflow and then
support that new workflow with the
technology or if we're just more going
to try to substitute technology for
people
so thank you for the clarification so we
are
looking at simplifying that workflow
with the use of this technology so
they're really the additional skill sets
that
um really isn't necessary we really have
the skill sets already so the
enhancements would automate some of the
process it would also assist staff to
manage it much more simplified currently
it's entirely manual
so when requests are received for an
appeal there is a great deal of manual
pulling of information and putting
together notifications for the
administrative Appeals Unit making sure
all that is done in a timely manner so
this is to basically increase the
capacity of staff and reduce that
workload
with each of the types of tracking
methods that we're looking at
implementing
I do have one further question of the um
ninety three thousand or ninety six
thousand folks are talking about uh
versus adults
currently the number of children or this
is as of uh uh earlier in the month uh
yeah two-thirds okay
okay could I have a motion to accept
on FIS 22363.
Senator Rosenwald second
oh the clerk please call the roll
call on 363. representative Edwards
no on 363
everybody's yes representative Earth yes
Riverson leischman yes Senator Daniels
yes Senator Bradley yes Senator gray yes
Senator Rosenwald yes Senator Susie
representative umbreger yes
and I'm sure the boat is nine to one the
okay
there were someone had some questions on
this
yes Santa Rosa Mall thank you
um
we had asked the department to respond
and I think you have but I wanted it to
be said publicly there is not a claw
back if somebody
loses Medicaid eligibility
after the end of the public health
emergency
um but there have been claims submitted
they would not be responsible for
repayment to the state or the federal
government
after the record Henry Littman the
Medicaid director for the State uh thank
you for the question Senator
um we are protected
um as long as we made the eligibility
determination correctly and we have a
did you
could you repeat that it didn't sound
thank you representative
what I was explaining that is if
um we
um incur costs for someone uh during the
continuous eligibility period we're
protected against a clawback
as long as we made the original
determination of Eligibility correctly
okay that thank you I guess my ears
weren't listening well I probably need
to speak up no that that's fine that's
fine are there any other questions
representative yes you know what I I
think you may not have completely
answered Senator rosenwald's question I
think she was also asking about
beneficiaries in other words if a
beneficiary is there any provision for a
clawback
that the beneficiary who improperly and
I'm not saying fraudulently or anything
like that but if they apply for benefits
they were awarded and then it's
determined that they shouldn't have that
for some reason they shouldn't have got
received them is there a club act
provision that they have to pay back
my understanding on that would be no
thank you
are there any further questions
seeing none
Senator Rosenwald moves do I have a
second
roll call on 366. representative Edwards
yes on 366. Eric Bots yes representative
or yes representative leishman yes
Senator Daniels yes Senator Bradley yes
Senator gray yes Senator Rosenwald yes
Senator Susie representative umberger
yes Madam chair the voters ten to zero
vote being 10-0 FIS
22 366 passes
we now turn to Tab 10 the regular
calendar
the uh the first item on the agenda is
FIS 22
341 from the Department of Safety
which is requesting expending uh
638 dollar 638 600 dollars in other
good morning Madam chair members of the
committee uh Steve Lavoy director of
administration for the Department of
Safety okay are there any questions on
the request for
um
seeing none representative leishman
moves
FIS
22 341.
roll roll call on 341. representative
Edwards yes on 341 chess representative
erf yes representative leishman yes
Senator Daniels yes Senator Bradley
Senator gray yes Senator Rosenwald yes
oh Senator Susie
represent umberger yes Madam chair the
vote is 10 to zero vote being 10-0 FIS
22 341 passes
thank you
we now turn to tab 11
and this is
um the Department of Natural and
cultural resources
okay good morning
good morning Sarah Stewart commissioner
of the Department of Natural and
cultural resources and with me is John
devivo who oversees Cannon Mountain at
Franconia Notch State Park okay thank
you
are there questions Senator Rosenwald
thank you madam chair good morning it's
still morning
um
it's like an eye test reading this chart
but
um I did notice that most of the fees
are staying the same however you've
raised through fees in three groups
versus the previous winter one is
seniors where the fees go up by about a
third
from last year or to this year and then
we have New Hampshire residents going up
10 percent and state employees going up
10 percent so given this is a state
resource I'm wondering
how you've decided
to put the fee increases on New
Hampshire residents our state employees
that are hard enough to retain and
seniors
thank you
thank you for the question for the
record my name is John devivo general
manager at Franconia Notch State Park
and Canada Mountain ski area so
in every year we do Market studies we
try to test and see where the ceilings
are and and what the market will bear in
addition to taking a look at what we've
been charging for several years in any
specific category and in those specific
areas we've we actually felt like we had
room to do minimal increases
that the percentages may appear to be
higher but the dollar figures are not
you're balancing what the market will
bear versus
how we could deploy this state resource
to benefit the people of the state yeah
whenever possible we try to defer to
our state
status and protect those specific price
areas for New Hampshire residents for
example we're happy to do our New
Hampshire resident Wednesday we've
brought that back we're happy to do all
of our New Hampshire resident
discounting which we enjoy doing but is
also part of an RSA in specific areas we
will look and see where there is room so
that we can remain viable and make some
Senator Daniels thank you
this last project we we added
significantly more to tourism to try to
I feel that by raising the fees on them
it sounds like we're now fighting
against tourism you know getting up here
but we'll charge you more so convince me
differently
well sir we do have specific costs that
we need to cover we do uh we do have a
requirement that we are
essentially at market value we do our
very best to be more of a value than our
five major competitors and it really uh
any competitors and we feel like we are
the very best at hitting value for price
paid in all those categories but like
with all other aspects of life our costs
have increased
and we do have a fiduciary
responsibility to remain viable as a
state agency
are there further questions
I do have a couple
and this deals with the uh ten dollars
um
I know we implemented a bus program and
the object was to get people to take the
bus and I
if I remember the parking fee was five
dollars is that correct
well I actually I'm sorry actually uh
the fee based shuttle system is for
ridership rather than parking
no right and so most people at this
point are dropping off at those Trail
heads uh and sending the driver North in
order to spend less money frankly
okay so the buses you pay to ride the
bus yes okay
and how many parking spaces do you have
within the notch we're approaching 2000
in total
the the item that we've put before you
would be the ability to charge for 202
spaces right at the two very primary
Trail heads uh one is the epicenter for
Franconia Ridge the other is the
epicenter for kinsman Ridge over on the
cannon side
all of the parking spaces are free
within the Notch and it's it's really
dependent upon which venue or which
Trailhead you would want to uh to go and
hike
but that influx of potentially eighty
thousand dollars would go a long way
toward having a direct impact upon our
ability to continue to run the hiker
shuttle which costs approximately ninety
thousand
between fuel
rentals of the vehicles themselves and
wages
if I if I could add the shuttle system
was implemented as a pilot program a
couple years ago we worked really
closely with DOT safety local
authorities to try to solve the problem
of 700 vehicles on a beautiful Saturday
parked along the highway with dogs
getting out and kids running around that
was really scary for all of us so we we
agreed as the park operations
to put together this shuttle system and
it worked really well it's worked really
well and Dot continues to support this
with their signage and their barriers
along the way so we just want to make
sure it's a sustainable operation and
we're looking for ways to cover the
expenses and we feel like these 200 plus
parking spots are really the Primo spots
that people would be willing to pay ten
dollars for and in contrast or to show
to show that this isn't a novel idea in
our Park system if you want to hike at
Mount Monadnock you pay 15 to park at
Mount Monadnock so it's it's a
similar situation there we we you cannot
hike Mount Monadnock without paying 15
to park
so it's it's an accepted fee
seeing none could I have a motion on FIS
rep Senator Bradley moves to table
seconded by
okay the motion to table for 348
yes
representative Emrick votes no
representative erf now
representative leishman yes
Senator Daniels yes
Senator Bradley
Senator gray yes Senator Rosenwald yes
Senator Susie
representative umberger yes
and I'm sure the vote is eight to two to
table
the vote being eight to two FIS 22 348
is laid on the table
thank you very much
uh we will now turn to tab 12.
and FIS
22 366.
uh for the Department of Health and
Human Services
requesting requesting that we review and
approval of a plan for implementation of
a pilot program for individuals with
developmental
disabilities between the ages of 18 and
21.
so
would you please introduce yourselves oh
sure um Chris Antonello associate
commissioner
Melissa Saints here the chief legal
officer
Nathan White sippo
thank you very much
um
representative Edwards you have yes
ma'am I think I have two questions
um
one
um if we approve this will the
department consider this the fiscal
committee approval of your of your plan
is this is this meant to be a plan or is
this meant to be something other than
the plan that we're supposed to approve
before you go forward sure so HP 1661
from this past legislative session it
required that the department come
forward
um once the unnecessary coordination for
the program had been sufficiently
completed and we need to request from
the fiscal committee that we may begin
implementation of the pilot program
there there's a there's also a secondary
requirement that on or before February 1
2023 the department will provide a
detailed report of the pilot program
plan that is is to come in the future
but this specific action is to comply
with the um the aforementioned provision
from 1661 that I had mentioned
uh uh thank you um
to what extent have you already or will
you be coordinating this item after as
presumably it's approved with the area
agency so the area agencies already been
in this Loop or not
um yes the area agencies have been in
this Loop they were part of the um whole
process during the legislative process
and then we will be meeting with a group
of Area Agency
um
um designated people to really walk
through every time you know we work on a
child being found eligible and and all
of those instances so yes there's a lot
of Engagement
so so would you be surprised if I had
heard from an area agency saying that
they had not been included and what they
were hoping you'd say in answer to that
question was not yet but they will be
um not always surprised because when we
work with agencies lots of times we take
Representatives that represent multiple
agencies or the entire system but
anytime
these children young adults would be
coming through the area agency system so
they would be involved prior to having
funding
um
first of all I don't believe this is a
plan
um what the priority order is when
will you bring back a plan I mean an
actual plan that says
you know here here's what we are
planning to do
under
emergency room ABCD
or whatever it is I mean I don't
I don't consider this to be a plan
I consider this to be a high level of
here's what we're looking to accomplish
so
this really is looking at filling a gap
that exists and based on the legislation
it is really targeting those children
young adults who are have not exited the
school system and are in need of
residential services and so those are
prioritized here and then throughout
what happens is then you go through the
individual planning process that you do
with any individual and family to
determine what is the next step to serve
them the detailed report that we are to
provide in February which is just a few
months away will really get into the
details as to who access the services
what types of services they needed so we
can really work on planning for the
thank you
so you're telling me February
is when I'll get a more detailed plan
you'll get a report in February this is
the plan just to get us started to
accept the funds so that we can begin to
assist those individuals who fall in
this Gap that exist in our state to
foreign
thank you I want to share the chairs
concerns uh particularly in the area of
funding you're talking about that's
going to cost 140
000 per person but I would expect the
plan to break down where that 140 000 is
expected to go so
um you know I saw this I was actually
kind of looking through to find out
where's the plan this seemed more like
an outline to me so so I I just want to
call to attention
um the the purpose of this item is to
comply with with the aforementioned
provision of H being 1661 and excuse me
Nathan bring your mic closer oh
thank you there we go
um what I wanted just to clarify is is
the purpose of this item the section
that we're citing is it it reads that if
if the department determines that all
necessary coordination for the pilot
program has been sufficiently completed
we may make a request to the fiscal
Committee of the general court to begin
implementation of the program on an
appropriate effective date
and and Chris uh Chris had cited um the
February 1 date and that's the date at
which we would bring that report so this
this isn't necessarily the comprehensive
plan what you'll see in February is a
lot more detail of that this is more a
compliance request to comply with that
specific provision of the state law that
was put into place and this is the
request for authorization to move
so I guess my question would be
why would we
why would we authorize you to spend
money to start a program that we may not
the legislature approved on this pilot
as part of the last legislative session
so according to um state law we are
required to do this pilot and this is
one of the steps that we have to take
and I'm going to ask Senator Bradley to
okay I would I would also state that
that the uh the bill that you just read
rev from also had the thing coming to
the fiscal committee which we look at
the monetary aspects of it too and right
now I just see a clump of money and I
it's going to go to serve those those
young adults that need the services and
then the report that we do in February
will give detailed information as
outlined in the legislation as to the
types of services the number of young
yes well
I'm just
Senator Bradley please thank you very
much Madam chair
so a little history
um the department brought forward a bill
that I sponsored for the Department
two years ago that was wide open that
anybody 18 to 21
um the potentially needed Services was
going to be able to obtain services in
this way
the area agency subjected to that
because of the some of the unknowns that
I think have been discussed here today
and
as I recall we in the Senate stripped
that piece out of that bill I think it
was Senate Bill 160
when the department again came to me to
file
another Omnibus type bill
um that provision was in the bill again
and I worked with the department and the
area agencies and came up with the
number of up to 20 kids to try to answer
some of the questions as that have been
raised by both the department and other
members here of the fiscal committee
today it would be my recommendation that
we go forward with it
um these are
individuals that are potentially in need
of services
um
we will learn a lot more from it and be
able to I I would hope figure out what
the demand could potentially be is it 20
kids or is it a thousand kids we don't
know the answer to that I don't think
you know the answer to that either right
and and but at the same time there are
families with disabled children that
have left the school system that until
they're 21 there's an obligation to
serve so it seemed
and both bodies passed it
although there was
um
as you remember Madam chair we had to
move this bill into the parking garage
we parked it right there in 1661 but it
was never
this piece was never really discussed as
I recall in any kind of
um
controversial way in all of the Senate
hearings and I think all of the house
hearings on the underlying bill that's
my recollection of the process
uh I will not argue at all that there's
a problem in 18 to 21
age group
okay I I have no problem with that uh
because I I certainly recognize that
that is a uh an area of
underserved I think is maybe the right
term that that I should use
but
your your pilot program as it stands
says
it's basically
looking at
your first first two items are homeless
for basically for homeless people
and your third item
is individuals already receiving the
maximum amount of services
through in-home support
so
okay unless the legislation said that
you were to focus on the homeless
that you know I I question whether those
should be number one and number two well
it's a young adult who meets the
eligibility criteria under RSA 171a so
they're already found eligible for
developmental Services System and they
do not have a place to live often times
these young adults show up in the
emergency room and they can't go home
um and so when we say homeless that is
determined as not individuals who would
be homeless under the homeless Services
System these are individuals through the
area agency system who are eligible
under RSA 171a that threshold has to be
met first and have no home to go to and
okay are there any further questions
no but Madam chair if I may
um
to go back to the uh what HHS is asking
I think more specifically even though it
says to in the item itself it's um I
should have taken a closer look at this
requestering review and approval of its
plan the chapter are itself and I'm
going to read it verbatim is that if the
department determines that all necessary
coordination for the pilot program has
been sufficiently completed the
department may make a request to the
fiscal Committee of the general court to
begin implementation of the pilot
program on the appropriation effective
date uh and sent it in basically what
happened Senator barely had mentioned
this is the legislature did appropriate
2.8 million dollars for these
individuals for a pilot program
um I think there's a cap of about 20
individuals but before HHS can even
spend dollar one uh they need fiscal to
say yep are you sure you've done all the
coordination for the pilot program and
you're ready to go and then fiscal will
say yes and you can be and suspended the
paragraph before and it could be a
little out of order in that
um in that chapter law that's where the
requirement that on February 1st 2023
the department shall provide a detailed
report of the pilot program plan that's
the first and only use of the word plan
to the Senate Health and Human Services
committee Center Finance
house children and family law house HHS
committee house finance as well as
fiscal not for approval but to provide
that to them and then what that chapter
law does is specifically outline what
the committee should expect to see
relative to what
Christine was mentioning the data on
utilization number of individuals Etc uh
so I think maybe the wording of the
request is causing some of the confusion
what the department needs before they
can even begin to spend that is the
approval of fiscal to begin the
implementation of the pilot program the
plan to be coming at a later date that
is not something that needs approval of
fiscal if that helps to confuse or
clarify the situation
I think the comment that uh
the explanation wasn't really very good
it's probably the most appropriate thing
you said okay uh are there any further
questions
seeing none could I have a motion to
approve
3336 moved by Senator Bradley seconded
by Senator Gray
will the clerk please call the roll roll
call on 336 representative Edwards I
have a conflict of interest in them
yes representative leishman yes Senator
Daniels no
uh Senator Bradley yes
Senator gray yes
Senator Rosenwald yes Senator Susie yes
representative umberger yes
uh Madam chair the vote is eight to one
okay the vote being eight in favor one
opposed and one abstained the motion
passes
okay thank you very much so we will look
forward to seeing a plan in February
all right we now turn to late item
22 371.
[Music]
which is in
tab
13.
uh
Department of Health and Human Services
is
um asking for dollars to develop a
sununu youth
Services Center critical Staffing
good morning or good afternoon Joe
you want to say something
sure you only just describe the item I'm
sorry I was expecting a question
um
so what we're seeking to do here with
support the letter actually comes from
Das with support from Das through their
uh recently authorized
retention and recruitment
Authority is to be able to provide a
retention and recruitment enhancement
for staff who work overtime shifts at
sysc
we've gotten into a very very difficult
Staffing situation in that building we
are now down to we need about 45
full-time youth counselors to run that
building appropriately we're now down to
20 full-time youth counselors to run
that building
we do have a handful of temporary staff
which were approved at a prior fiscal
committee here that contract is to be
able to have up to 18 at a time at this
nine of those filled
it's been very very difficult to hire
recruit and retain staff in addition
there has already been an enhancement
approved by jnc on their salaries
despite that it still has been
incredibly difficult to hire retain and
recruit staff
that's put us into a position where
we're having to rely even more greatly
on overtime than in the past and staff
are really struggling to keep up with
that over time
the department has since put out a
request for any Department staff who are
qualified to be able to be trained in
working as a YC there and to receive
overtime compensation for working there
in order to have enough overtime hours
filled we believe is necessary to have
an additional enhancement for folks to
entice them to come in and work the
overtime shifts so that's where this
comes in the idea to try to entice more
people to come into being voluntarily
working overtime shifts at sysc or to
provide additional compensation for
folks who might be newly hired
attracted by the opportunity to earn
additional overtime while working in the
facility the plan sets forth that
anybody who works more than 24 hours of
overtime in a pay period would be
eligible for a 300 bonus in their
paycheck
okay thank you uh are there any
questions representative Edwards uh
thank you madam chair thank you Mr
ribson
um so uh I the fundamental problem that
you're trying to cope with as I
understand it is that we have uh on the
books in the rsas a closure date of 30
March and there is no replacement plan
in law at this point and that's the
that's the 800 pound gorilla making it
difficult to recruit and retain is is
that correct that is a huge contributing
factor I believe there are probably
other contributing factors right such as
you know underlying salary which we've
tried to address such as the the general
Cloud over the facility given the the
horrible things that have happened in
the past there but yes uh we saw
actually once we were unable to have a
resolution on that issue in the last
legislative session an additional third
of our current working YC's had resigned
because they had seen that
you know there was not necessarily a
future for them and it's incredibly
difficult to operate a facility when you
have that type of ambiguity over the
yes please okay so
um so it seems like it may be necessary
but not sufficient
to
extend the closure dates so that at
least the retention problem is minimized
I don't see how recruiting can really
benefit until we have a replacement plan
until we know what the future looks like
I I think we can keep people around but
recruiting them will be tough without a
replacement plan that's my theory what
do you think I believe that's true but
not necessarily the entirety of it I do
think that you know if there is you know
public signaling and support that this
is going to be resolved that too will
help right I think a lot of this is that
folks really aren't quite sure what's
going to happen and you know even if it
takes time for the legislature to come
up with that replacement plan and to
extend out the dates into the next
session which I don't believe there's
any alternative to that right I don't
believe there's a possibility to do
anything sooner than the beginning of
the next session the fact that even this
conversation has started and there's
been public reports about the extension
of all of this has already helped us in
these conversations with staff and
trying to say look there is a future
sure people are working towards this but
it's incredibly important that progress
continued to be made so that people
continue to see that they do have a
future
excuse me may I yeah so I think I I
think I've heard you described a
three-legged stool here that the issues
that's causing your recruiting and
retention problems you could summarize
maybe in three legs one that we have a a
closure date on record that
um you have salary issues just to bring
people in and that you have sort of a a
Goodwill messaging uh component of it
that if if people in the department are
hearing that the legislature and the
public is interested in working on that
first problem which is the closure date
that that that those three things in
combination could help address your
concerns yes I believe that is there a
I think I I think that's I mean I think
that's accurate that's what's coming to
mind
uh I mean I don't think there's anyone
in the legislature that believes that
this new center is going to close on 31
March
you know I don't know how I don't know
how you reassure people that they'll
have jobs on one April but um it's you
know
it's not going to close it can't
so um I don't know if that helps or not
but we'll do our level best to get
legislation through quickly
uh in uh in January
that will hopefully help with um
you know with people understanding that
there is a future
although it may not you know 45 people
is what you were talking you would
probably require 45 for any new
act uh
building or whatever so
I know it's a problem and um but we'll
get there
appreciate it thank you all right are
there any further questions uh Senator
Susie
shoes but I wonder if you could just
update us I believe with respect to the
salary issue collective bargaining
negotiations play a huge part in this
and
the role the state has played vis-a-vis
the employees I I think has also
exacerbated your problem I wonder if you
could speak to any specific issues that
might be addressed soon in that
bargaining agreement yeah so the the
immediate the immediate or short-term
attempt to try to address that was
through a salary enhancements which were
approved by GNC a little bit less than a
year ago
that pushed the Sy that pushed the sysc
Frontline staff salaries to really be in
the range of like 15 to 20 an hour which
if you go and look at what folks are
paying at grocery stores and such right
in the current environment that's not
incredibly competitive
um and that was after the salary
enhancements right so I think this is
all happening in the context of a few
other things right that I that I don't
think we have direct control over in the
immediate term but that I do think in
the long term should be or in the
intermediate term should be thought
about right
um one you know we do have an overall
Workforce issue in the state in general
and specifically in areas of direct care
right so Direct Care in all different
settings but particularly in my in my
wheelhouse and where I'm concerned is
around people who provide Direct Care in
residential settings that's true for a
private residential programs it's true
for sysa and it's not just a New
Hampshire issue every state in the
country is facing the same thing I get
Clips sent to my email every morning
from around the country for Juvenile
Justice and child welfare related issues
and you'll see a story that sounds just
like this all over the place so I think
there's a big issue there and that the
the workforce the compensation for that
type of work hasn't really kept pace
with the rest of the economy so I do
think there's an opportunity to think
about what is an intermediate or
long-term solution to that problem what
we're really proposing at this moment is
just a Band-Aid to try to get us get us
thank you are there further questions
seeing none could I have a motion to
accept
seconded by representative erf
well the clerk please call the roll
we'll call for 371. representative
Edwards yes the 371. memory coach yes
representative erf yes representative
leishman yes Senator Daniels yes Senator
Bradley
Senator gray yes Senator Rosenwald yes
Senator Susie representative umberger
yes Madam chair the vote is 10-0 vote
being ten to zero FIS 22 371 passes
so Mr Kane I understand you have
something for us yes thank you madam
chair
um the administrative procedures of the
committee adopted at the um beginning a
couple years ago uh requires that our
office request authority to fill a
position when found a candidate and have
a vacancy we do have a vacancy which is
funded we have identified a candidate
who has accepted our job offer pending
approval from fiscals so I would just
ask the committee's approval to fill in
auditor position
Senator Susie moves Senator Rosenwald
seconds
do I need a roll call uh either show her
hands roll call whatever you're
comfortable with uh show of hands on
whatever Mr Kane hiring somebody oh yes
yes what's really exciting is that uh
you actually have someone to fill the
position
we do we we kind of cheated she worked
for us before a few years ago so we had
a little uh leg up on that but it
doesn't matter how how it happened it's
good that it happened
okay we have
um several information items
and
um we have a
briefing on
um
pfas in our landfills
so are there any questions on any of the
other information items
yes Lottery
okay
hi Jim Durst CFO New Hampshire Lottery
Commission
uh thanks for taking my question so I
think I noted a decline of about 6.7
million in sales could you just tell us
why we're seeing a decline yes uh
there's really two factors in there uh
During the covid period our sales
increased greatly
uh with sharp sharp increases that were
unexpected at the time
so we're having the combination of that
coming back a little more to reality
what I would call reality is the finance
person but
um coming back more into line still over
prior years if you go back to 22 and 20
we're still above those numbers just not
going where 21 was
uh secondary we also see the rising
prices of food gas prices things like
that which obviously have especially gas
I have a direct direct effect of when
you buy gas
and go into that store you don't have as
much free money to spend on tickets all
right uh thanks thanks Madam chair
you know it's interesting I got the same
answer from uh
Charlie McIntyre so they're talking to
each other which is which is good to
know so thank you very much thank you
very much you're welcome
so uh d h a or yeah right Environmental
folks if you would
uh I think all of you received a
copy of
the briefing
so
this kind of um
there was something that
came about that said this is a this is a
problem that
um we're going to be facing
probably in the in the next budget and
I I don't know where
we're going to get all this money from
so if you would commissioner please
thank you madam chair for the record my
name is Mike wimsat I service director
of the waste management division for New
Hampshire des and with me today is Jamie
O'Rourke who is a hydrogeologist in our
house of space remediation Bureau and
much of his work focuses on landfills
and landfill monitoring uh as as the
chair indicated there's a question that
came up in a prior meeting about pfas
particularly as it relates to our
landfills in the state and as it relates
specifically to its presence in leachate
which you'll as you'll learn from Jamie
is a significant management issue for
for landfills that do collect it
um so uh I'm with that I'm just gonna I
know we've got running late here today
I'm going to turn it right over to Jamie
he's got a presentation that I believe
has been shared with the committee
members probably runs about 15 minutes
or so in length and and we'll be happy
to answer any questions either along the
way or after Jamie's completed
foreign
good afternoon we do have copies of the
presentation if if someone doesn't have
I've got 25 more here if you if you
please go ahead thank you very much good
afternoon everyone
um we were invited over to give a quick
little discussion on pfas occurrence in
leachate at New Hampshire landfills and
on the interest of time I'll I'll be
moving rather quickly on some of these
slides that are more uh high level
within the first several Pages these are
numbered as well if you'll note in the
bottom right hand corner we have a the
first page here is a listing of the
active lined Municipal Solid Waste
landfills here in New Hampshire
along with their locations the next page
is simply a listing of the various
wastes that can be found or disposed of
in New Hampshire landfills not all
landfills can take all of these wastes
but a majority of them and all of them
for certain will be taking Municipal
solid waste and wastewater treatment
plant sludge which we'll be discussing
in a few minutes
as we move along here landfill leachate
Management in New Hampshire leachate is
actually defined in the solid waste
rules it means a liquid including any
suspended components in the liquid which
has contacted or passed through Salt
passed through solid waste as that
liquid passes through a landfilled waste
Mass it leeches or extracts chemicals or
constitutes from the wastes as those
waste break down
along with pfas this can include
numerous different chemicals and
compounds as well as the pfas organic
compounds heavy metals chlorides
nitrates so on and so forth the material
ends up being quite a quite a noxious
fluid very thick viscous almost like a
brine or a thick soup if you will very
following the discovery and of the
extent of pfas impacts to the southern
southern part of New Hampshire Des
started becoming concerned about the
potential for pfas within the landfills
and specifically the landfill leachate
in 2018 Des conducted an initial
sampling survey of leachate from nine
landfills in New Hampshire that includes
the six Active landfills as well as
three closed landfills that also
generate leachate the results results
were rather rather interesting and very
wide-ranging a wide variety of pfas were
detected at varying concentrations
across the board all nine landfills had
pfas it wasn't there wasn't necessarily
a theme or a Rhyme or Reason as to the
scale or size or even age of the
landfill whether it be closed or still
active
the next study that kind of came to our
uh attention was actually our
neighboring state of Vermont in 2019
they required their their only operating
landfill to conduct a study of potential
pfest sources in waste Stream So
essentially what they did is they had
their landfills uh sample the waste as
it was coming into the facility trying
to determine where are we seeing this
pfas and our leachate coming from well
the answer was it's pretty much across
the board there's a snippet of a slide
at the bottom of the page that I've
included and you can see there's pfas
detections across the board from sludge
to bulky items textiles carpeting
mattresses couches so on and so forth so
there is as we all know now which we
didn't necessarily know as much in 2019
as pfas is rather prevalent across our
society
so in New Hampshire the current
management of leachate is rather
Universal leachate is captured in the
landfill's liner system below the waist
uh that's there and it's either shipped
or piped to a wastewater treatment plant
it's about 50 50 versus trucked versus
shipped with our active landfills at the
wastewater treatment plant and within
the process itself there is a negligible
destruction of pfas in fact it
partitions off to the water effluent as
well as the biosolid sludge material
as a result there's relative impacts on
the back end the receiving water quality
has will show impacts from pfas and the
receipt and the sludge itself shows
impacts as well potentially limiting its
management options instead of being able
to possibly be used in land spreading or
composting one of the other options is
that it goes to landfills in fact a
majority of it does
there is one active landfill in New
Hampshire that actually pre-treats its
lead shape which we'll be talking about
in a little bit
um it wasn't necessarily designed to be
simple to be uh pre-treating for pfas is
uh the turnkey landfill in Rochester
they've actually been pre-treating their
leachate since the 1990s so well before
our knowledge of pfas uh came around
I'll talk about in a little bit more
detail they've been doing some
interesting work that we've been
discussing with them but as I outlined
above there's essentially this cyclical
relationship between landfills and
wastewater treatment plants a landfill
generates lead shade it gets shipped to
a wastewater treatment plant the
wastewater treatment plant generates a
biosolid and many in most cases it gets
shipped back to a ship to a landfill
there are obviously a couple of
offshoots off of that relationship with
the water effluent which may come off
and impact streams and and rivers and
then also the biosols component in some
cases there are some beneficial uses
that are there in which they have been
on the next page we have a a table of
the various volumes of leachate that
have been generated at the at the sixth
Municipal Solid Waste landfills across
New Hampshire these are the last three
years of numbers that we have as you can
see the numbers vary greatly from
location to location uh but also from
within facility uh from year to year as
well now the numbers obviously will
relate to the landfill size and scale of
operations but there are some
operational steps that a landfill can
take to limit the amount of water that
infiltrates into the waste Mass if you
use a tighter cover on a daily basis you
can shed some of that water instead of
generating as much so there are some
potential steps you can take to to limit
landfill each eight generation
at the bottom of the page there are six
closed landfills that also generate
leachate they generate leachate at a
much much smaller rate given that they
are closed they are capped with an
impervious material to prevent liquid
and water and rain water today from
migrating through the waste mass and
generating more leachate essentially
with a with a liner underneath and the
cap on the top we've created somewhat of
a closed system so the leachate is
coming out and those numbers drop off
precipitously after closure almost
um we wanted to take the time today to
discuss at least very briefly the
occurrence of pfas and groundwater at
New Hampshire landfills we obviously
have this these occurrences in leachate
and we have been aware of and sampling
land around landfills consistently
Des required groundwater sampling from
4p fast it all lined and unlined
landfills that have groundwater release
detection or groundwater management
permits so groundwater monitoring
permits that run in perpetuity
essentially for the landfill's Existence
and Beyond
as of March of 2022 90 of the landfills
have been sampled for pfas this includes
all the lined landfills and all the
active landfills as well
91 of those have had pfas detections 77
percent have had pfas detected over
ambient groundwater quality standards or
agqs standards for one or more of the
four pfas that we regulate
a not unsignificant number is 22 and a
half percent on that last line we've had
that that number of landfills that have
either had pfas detected below standard
or not detected at all in groundwater
sampling around them
at the bottom of the page there's a
table where those numbers and
percentages were derived from
um just a
just a little reference point for you
when you look at the lined landfills
some of the line landfills in New
Hampshire have online landfills
associated with them either butting up
against them or right next door so when
we calculate those numbers when we look
at that monitoring data those might be
representative more of the online
landfill as opposed to some kind of
operational challenge with the line
system
the next page is essentially uh the the
same numbers presented in a slightly
different way just a simple pie chart
for us you can see the three quarters of
the landfills have detections over agqs
and the other 22 percent how they're
divided we have uh had 174 landfills in
New Hampshire screened for pfas at this
time we're hoping and anticipating being
able to get the rest on board as well
one note here the the data from this
groundwater information uh was submitted
uh previously in our status report on
the occurrence of pfas contamination in
New Hampshire dated June of 2022 much
bigger report that I believe was
um
obviously with groundwater impacts at
landfills Des is always concerned about
drinking water because groundwater is
such an essential source of drinking
water in New Hampshire as a result there
has been extensive drinking water
sampling around landfills conducted by
the responsible parties municipalities
and such pfas has been detected in
drinking water supply Wells exceeding
agqs at six closed landfill sites
totaling 24 water supplies that have
been impacted
each of those impacted Water Supplies
has been provided a permanent potable
water solution so either some kind of
treatment system on their water supply
well or a connection to a water utility
or they're being provided bottled water
until such a permanent solution can be
provided by the responsible party in
approximately half of these cases
contaminants other than pfas were
previously detected at the water supply
Wells above their respected agqs so
about 12 of these were already being
monitored for other impacts from a
landfill and as a result of pfas coming
onto our radar screen we decided that
they needed a sample for pfas as well
and it was found as part of the process
those residents were probably already on
treatment systems already
uh at the bottom to note to note uh to
date there have been no detections of
pfas over agqs and water supply Wells
that have been sampled near active
landfills
so we framed the the challenge to frame
the issue a little bit and what are some
potential steps we can take in the
future to deal with this deal with
leachate
um we could continue on with the current
practice where wastewater treatment
plants uh are required to just meet
their applicable standards so if if
there were and will be surface water
standards for pfas enacted the
wastewater treatment plant would end up
needed to be able to comply with those
that would also relate to possibly the
sludge disposal whether it be
limitations on their ability to be used
um one of the things we could do if we
could wanted to consider a requirement
to pre-treat the leachate before it's in
place into the wastewater treatment
plants process you could have on-site
pre-treatment infrastructure at the
landfills you could develop a
wastewater treatment plant so that it's
not getting under the system one of the
other ideas that has been thrown around
a little bit and has received some
positive uh positive feedback is the
idea of a regional pre-treatment
facility where these landfills bring
their leachate so that it can be treated
appropriately by a state-of-the-art type
facility and and then have it disposed
of at a wastewater treatment plant you
could co-locate this with a waste
recruitment plant possibly
um
one of the other things we need to
consider as we go through this process
and evaluation is is what's the
significance of the benefit by removing
the pfast that leachate brings into a
wastewater treatment plant how much pfas
are we removing from the total that may
be coming out of the pipe as we talked
about the potential waste waste that go
into landfills we know that pfas is is
prevalent throughout our society where
it was raining this morning if we had
Gore-Tex or some kind of other
waterproofing on we might have had pfas
and a part of our clothing Cosmetics so
on and so forth so
there will be significant pfas and
wastewater treatment plant already how
much how much help are we giving by
removing this pfest from the leachate
there is significant sampling that's
been being done by DES in the Water
Division to be able to make some
informed decisions on this as we move
forward
so there are treatment technologies that
would be available for us to be able to
treat leachate the first three may look
rather familiar to you they've been used
extensively across New Hampshire to
treat drinking water supplies that have
been impacted by pfas with granulated
activated carbon ion exchange resin and
reverse osmosis
as I indicated earlier one of the
challenges that at this stage with
dealing with leachate is it's is its
viscosity is its components is it
suspended solids if you were to apply
pfas to one of these Technologies
directly you would end up fouling the
system almost into almost instantaneous
on a daily basis so what you end up
needing to do is have what's called a
treatment trainer sequence of treatments
that can get the leachate to the point
of being able to use this technology
it's not impossible in fact it is is it
is done it just adds a great develop
complexity and maintenance related to
um there are new in emerging
contaminants or new and emerging
Technologies for these emerging
contaminants foam fractionation which is
the generation of a pfast foam off the
top of the leachate that could be
skimmed off and disposed of
stabilization or encapsulation which is
the creation essentially of a solid or a
concrete that can then be disposed of
back into the landfill one of the ones
we're most interested in is
supercritical water oxidation it is a
relatively new technology that's being
tested out there but it actually applies
heat and pressure to be able to destroy
the pfas compound obviously very ideal
very much on the front end there are
some pilot studies out there that we are
aware of in fact the Wastewater
engineering Bureau has received a
infrastructure Grant to be able to run a
pilot treatment a pilot study on
treatment of leachate from a wastewater
treatment or from a landfill prior to
its being delivered to a wastewater
treatment plant they're hoping to get
numbers out of that within 20 in in 2023
in the summer summer of 2023
um the turkey landfill right of
Rochester landfill excuse me they've
also been running their own pilot
studies as a commercial entity they've
been doing this
um and we became aware of uh some rather
interesting information uh that they
provided to us and that they've had
successful runs of of running a pilot
study on a full-scale basis uh they're
hoping to be able to take the next steps
into the future so we hope to be able to
learn a lot from them as they move on
with actual operational uh uh Tendencies
uh when it comes to the treatment of
leachate
uh in summary there are six Active
Municipal Solid Waste landfills in New
Hampshire that are generating
approximately 96 million gallons of
leachate per year leachate quantities
generated generated very widely by
landfill uh generally based on landfill
size but not exclusively there are some
operational steps you can take the limit
that generation operational time frames
and landfill sizes do not always
correlate with the concentrations of
pfas and leachate pfas is found on a
wide ranging number of waste types there
is this cyclical relationship we
discussed uh between landfills and
wastewater treatment plants where the
landfill generates leachate gets sent to
a wastewater treatment plant the
wastewater treatment plant generates
biosolid it gets sent back to the
landfill itself
there are potential ha treatment options
as we discussed they haven't been fully
vetted necessarily at an operational
level at New Hampshire landfills and uh
as I discussed on the last slide there
are some pilot studies that we're going
to get some information from over the
next year or so
on last page I've included my contact
information as direct as well as
director wimsatz we are available for
questions if there's time now or if you
have questions at another time you can
oh go ahead Senator gray sorry uh since
I'm also a city councilman in Rochester
uh the history of why their pre-treat in
Rochester has to do with nitrogen and
nitrate because of the discharges in the
conchico river which is impaired for and
so it didn't have anything to do with
PF compounds I just want to make sure
that that's clear and waste management I
didn't even know that they were running
a pilot on pfas yeah they um I had a
conversation with them just very
recently where I mentioned that we were
going to have this discussion and I
wanted a bit of an update as to what
they were doing and they dropped this on
us in a favorable way there's no
requirement from us for them to be
they're pre-treating their leachate as
you discussed it's a local local matter
and the pfas component I think is a
matter of disposal for an economic
standpoint at one point they were
shipping their leachate all the way down
to I think New Jersey at some point
that's not sustainable for them so they
I think invested in monies into trying
to take the next steps into keeping it
it's rather scary when your landfill
says to your wastewater treatment plant
you cannot bring your leachate to me
anymore
because then you're kind of looking
I don't want it in my backyard but uh
it's it's the kind of thing that I'm I'm
really really concerned that this is
going to blow up in our faces and that's
that I think is a real problem
I mean everybody that has a
you know doesn't have a
has to have their uh tanks pumped all
that goes to some
wastewater treatment plant
and it's my understanding that the
thing that you have at home is higher
than what comes into the wastewater
treatment plant through the sewer system
so it's
I don't know
well thank you madam chair if I may um
you raised a really good point so it as
as with many topics it's very sometimes
very location and facility specific
um you know a landfill that sends its
leachate to a fairly large scale
wastewater treatment plant that has many
millions of gallons a day of flow that
it's treating
um that daily shipment may not represent
a significant portion of the influent to
that plant and in fact as Jamie
indicated it may not represent a
significant proportion of the pfas that
comes to that plant in any given day and
therefore doesn't necessarily influence
the final concentration in the receiving
stream most of those large volume
Wastewater plants discharge to a
relatively large river you know
receiving body on the other hand there
may be other small Wastewater plants as
we have a few of them in New Hampshire
that don't have the the luxury of
discharging to a receiving stream a
river they may do a direct groundwater
discharge through Rapid infiltration
basins or some other such technology and
in those cases the impact to that if
effluent discharge has an immediate
impact on groundwater quality and so for
those types of facilities it's a much
more difficult question so as with most
things the the the best solution or even
the need for a solution may be dependent
on the particular wastes involved the
particular facility and the
circumstances are operating under so
we're looking at all those we're working
we're very close working relationships
with all of our Wastewater plants and
when they run into problems like that
we're working to help them and actually
the the pilot study that um Jamie
mentioned is actually focused on one of
those plants that has a rapid
infiltration Basin to try to help them
kind of get their arms around the
problem
are there any further yes uh
representative leishman all right thank
you madam chair um is your name
representative Leachman oh I'm sorry it
could be he would like it to be oh I
pass his cards out at the bar
oh I'm I'm so sorry I uh okay so on page
15 you have uh
several treatments in in health care uh
prior to worrying about treatments we
build in a whole preventive medicine
prevention program and I'm just curious
if if there's also a prevention aspect
of this that that you guys are including
in your thinking but is not in this
report
yeah thank you represent that's a great
question and and yes the answer that is
yes on both a state scale and a national
scale so on the state scale
um when now as I said we have close
working relationships so it's in our
Water Division and these Wastewater
plants when they start and we've been
and we've been doing at the state level
in to assist them a lot of testing to
understand what they're getting in for
influent concentrations of pfas as well
as what they're discharging out you know
for treated effluent and when they find
a problem that seems anomalous when they
see concentrations that are particularly
High some plants have even gone to the
trouble of going and it helps you
understand things better going to
different locations in their collection
system to try to find out if we are
getting increased pfas where is it
coming from and can they tie it to a
particular commercial or industrial
facility that may be using pfas
containing materials in their
manufacturing processes and then ending
up discharging them in their Wastewater
so there's a lot of work that's been
done to identify that and then that's
when you get to the prevention piece if
there's a a problem if that facility can
use another material that doesn't use
pfast to get it out that's a great
solution if they have to use it for
their particular manufacturing then they
can look at removing that pfas prior to
just getting into their Wastewater and
discharging to the Wastewater system so
that's sort of the state level and and
local level prevention that we work on
also there's a lot of discussion
nationally that at the end of the day if
we're going to solve this pfas problem
we kind of have to significantly
absolutely have to significantly reduce
the presence of pfas and commerce that
means that there's probably a lot of
uses for these materials while while
helpful and convenient may not be
entirely necessary and when you run you
know cost-benefit analysis of you know
the benefit that that product gives you
by using pfas versus the cost associated
with managing wastes or the waste itself
when you throw away that product those
are those there's a lot of work going on
there trying to really reduce the amount
of pfas that's used and Industry is
already making steps there they have
lots of reasons not to be famous for
having pfast in their products so
there's a lot of work going on to try to
reduce or eliminate the use of pfas in
uh thank you so as I'm looking at the
Alternatives I assume that one of the
big factors is not only just the
efficiency the effectiveness of these
techniques but uh but also the energy
consumption yes I I would assume that
some of these are energy Hogs more than
others and so so that's all part of your
analysis I I presume that is correct
there's as with most things there's
never a perfect sort of Silver Bullet
everything has pros and cons and again
the the answer for one facility may be
very different than another you know if
you're treating drinking water and
you're a small facility or even a large
facility granulated activated carbon
turns out to be a very time tested
effective and caught and though
expensive still a cost-effective means
of treating drinking water as Jamie
mentioned when you start talking about
treating leachate it gets more difficult
you got to do a lot more pre-treatment
and in fact uh Senator gray mentioned
the turnkey landfill in Rochester the
work that they did to remove nitrate
that goes back to the 90s the treatment
train they developed there for many
years has had a series of steps which is
which is which ends with a reverse
osmosis step which you couldn't do on
untreated leachate but but they once
they've treated pre-treated it
sufficiently they can do that they had
no way of necessarily knowing it but
even when we weren't paying attention we
didn't know much about pfas their pre
their treatment through the reverse
osmosis process was removing pfas so the
the effluent that they were sending or
the treated pre-treated leachate that
they were sending to the Rochester City
Wastewater Plant had largely had the
represent representative Leachman thanks
Madam chair
uh Mike I'm sure the chairman is correct
as far as this is becoming an explosive
situation but is the department looking
at additional sources of funding to help
correct or do you plan to ask for
additional funding in the next budget to
address this issue
well as you can imagine we have we have
a lot of things going on with pfas and
over time funding has been provided to
the to the agency through some general
fund
Appropriations to help particularly
drinking water plants put on treatment
there's been a fair amount of
significant amount of federal money
that's been made available for that
we also have
access to the drinking one and
groundwater trust fund which is provided
in a number of cases some funding for a
variety of both research and treatment
processes are projects we've done some
research we need to really understand
where we have pfas and soils where we
have pfas where does it occur in
groundwater and drinking water in the
states so we've used some funding to do
those studies and we've also our primary
focus is to be make sure that people
aren't drinking contaminated water so
much of the work we've done and the
monies that we've spent have been on a
combination of testing to understand
where we have it occurring in drinking
water and then making sure we get
funding to both community and Municipal
Water Systems to get treatment on so
that they can serve Clean safe water so
the the short answer to that is yes we
continue to seek funding and and and
work with this specific issue
um you know I think as you may have
surmised from Jamie's presentation
um
in some respects this issue is is that
the market is sort of driving a lot of
it we're doing a lot of the work that
we've described here to work with our
Wastewater plants understand where the
problem is and how to solve it but in
fact
um the the landfills and the Wastewater
plants together have a lot of incentive
to try to get this out of their systems
so as you as as was presented uh by
Jamie you know the turnkey landfill
which is the biggest operating landfill
in the state has already been doing work
to to Really develop pretty Advanced
procedures for pre-treating leachate
um and the Wastewater plants help to
drive that because if at some point a
Wastewater Plant decides we don't want
to take your leachate anymore because we
don't think we want to have to worry
about it in our treated effluent that
comes back to the landfill to find a
solution so one of the things that I
think we may look to do is
have further discussions with the
landfills and with the Wastewater
Community to under understand whether a
and Jamie touched on this whether a
regional pre-treatment facility would be
an effective and a cost-effective means
of
improving the quality of leachate that
eventually gets delivered to these
Wastewater plants for treatment and
Disposal so there's a there's a lot
going on there and and we still have yet
a lot of work to do and a lot to learn
thank you thanks Madam chair
uh Senator Bradley reminded us that uh
they they were just given 25 million in
pfas remediation money but
whether or not whether or not any of
that will go to the Wastewater side I
don't know but uh it is a it's a it's an
issue that needs needs a lot of thought
and I truly appreciate it Mr winstat for
your
presentation and uh and your concern
it's our pleasure thank you and if there
are follow-up questions about Jamie and
I are happy to feel them uh just feel
free to reach out to us using the
contact information in the slideshow
if no one cares
adjourned
potato
es no
um